okay we're back [ __ ] and we're doing
operation crook wagon and this is going
to be dangerous but we're gonna do it I
can't not just let's go
yeah [ __ ] this is going to be a [ __ ]
day it's the first one it doesn't matter
okay
[Music]
guy Ranger people log Green to deploy
again that's my son back again it a
terminal connected to the advent network
through one of their facilities in this
area was left exposed ah one frame for a
second previous collision attempt we
think it may be possible to recover data
critical to the aliens latest operation
and stop their progress but we'll have
to move fast
Advent is already working to close the
connection removing sources from the
area lock it down and recover that data
yeah bad it bad bay
yeah bad it let's do this
that's kept s15 say access point we're
after is just ahead
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] miles away the
resistance we're all safe Sam gasps that
khanseb camshaft cam okay who's the
first [ __ ]
sergeant gunner that's correct
double-time
and it may patrol um Bali [ __ ] okay
where's sniper [ __ ] she's going all the
way to the [ __ ] top bad Bay got it
moving
these guys are getting ready to blast
their [ __ ] deck open that's what
they're going to be doing
got it covered
don't step on it don't step on it
think again not [ __ ] they got him
[ __ ] see me they got it oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
okay this [ __ ]
she's got to go we're all the way to the
[ __ ] top affirmative okay this guy
he's on his way out
[ __ ] wait I have a better chance of
just shooting this guy that kill now
[ __ ] lot for a grenade actually now
this guy should do the [ __ ] for a
grenade no this wants to kill this guy
go patch him up
can this guy do anything else yeah yeah
ready for a surprise eliminate these
[ __ ] I pick a chance of shooting this
[ __ ] is that
moving out yeah I don't know the sale
engineer what Ottoman troops here look
you smell that [ __ ] don't share my place
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] ego got me flanked
well okay
bums away I can kill this guy with this
let's talk to that one [ __ ] go oh [ __ ]
I literally have no idea okay got it
moving
gonna help them hear this [ __ ]
rolling it amazes that no one ever
questioned how these factories work meat
comes out but you don't see any
livestock going in do you that's what
she said
let's go moving out where is that other
alien got it covered
we're near the objective commander we
have confirmation of the exposed access
point solid copy
well I'll go on there where the [ __ ]
that robot dude go I betcha he's like
[ __ ] here
good to go
it's good even more aliens watch your
bet
copy that there we go
there he is
[ __ ]
ten-four look at that
well do
living on target locations
I don't you spotted okay get with a lot
of them again yeah [ __ ] go
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] kind of far but [ __ ] it [ __ ] [ __ ]
you spread it doubt that all right nice
shot [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] jet
power
Oh daddy okay an SMSF okay
like sesang system Hackett
I can't hack [ __ ] got income okay so
what happens in our okay we've confirmed
successful acquisition of the Advent
files eliminate any remaining hostels in
the area fire sniper rifle we gotta kill
this [ __ ] great for hey cow's ass okay
I was dead it was that [ __ ] it yeah
that's what I'm talking about
[ __ ] I got one more move I'm
sure I could kill this [ __ ] yeah that's
talking about that's what I'm talking
about
promoted okay now shake our this batch a
Shia callus batch
and I [ __ ]
I got to make sure this one dies she's
our rookie so if she dies okay ah you
[ __ ] on my toe or what holy [ __ ] I left
a down a for now who the [ __ ] I'm gonna
do
clothing on target position now [ __ ]
shut that [ __ ] if I cannot get out that
ever watch
so I show us the best hey Dad he's not
that [ __ ] [ __ ] moving I could fire yeah
right to the [ __ ] wall
well [ __ ] [ __ ] mess good copy
moving on target let me pop this [ __ ]
come on come on [ __ ] mad get it
together
I'm s
that is what I am talking about doggy
down status confirmed that's again this
is damn good mission that is confirmed
mission accomplished
excellent that's what I'm talking about
boy that's what I'm talking about
okay bad man that's what I'm talking
about boys huh [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
awesome look at her you know she's
getting a [ __ ] tonight thank you